Hey Wisecrack, Jared here.
It may be the New Year, but we’ve still
got a massive hangover from 2017’s final
blockbuster Bright, a film that left us cross-eyed
and confused.
Netflix spent 90 million dollars combining
two of our favorite things- the dystopian
fantasy and the buddy cop -- and left us with
the world’s most expensive “WTF?”
We’ve been scratching our heads trying to
figure how such an awesome concept -- think
Rush Hour 2 of the Deathly Hallows or Lethal
Weapon of the Rings ended up feeling as big
as shitshow as David Ayer’s last movie.
Like other fantasy films, it SEEMS to be using
its imaginary setting to tell a compelling
story, while also illuminating truths about
our society.
However, both its plot AND any potential underlying
meaning become completely muddled by the film’s
poor world-building, lousy character development,
and ill-suited metaphors about American racial
politics.
So let’s find out what happened in this
week’s Wisecrack Edition on Bright- “What
Went Wrong.
As always, major, minor and vaguely judgemental
spoilers ahead.
Head Scratcher #1: Building the World.
Every time you see a film, you’re asked
to take a leap of faith and accept some kind
of proposition - that loving parents occasionally
leave their youngest kid behind when they
go on vacation or that Keanu Reeves is the
most badass assassin EVER.
But when you’re watching a fantasy that
plays with gravity, object permanence or the
entertainment potential of a wardrobe filmmakers
have to convince you to take a Mount Everest-sized
leap off a peak of disbelief and land with
their characters in a distant galaxy, Middle
Earth, or a far away distant land in a wardrobe.
A good script gets the audience to buy into
its world by explaining the rules of that
world coherently and concisely… and getting
the heck on with the story.
Think of how effective Lord of the Rings is
in briefing the audience on the history of
Middle Earth’s most sought-after jewelry.
“It began with the forging of the Great
Rings….
Three were given to the Elves...Seven to the
Dwarf Lords...And Nine ... were gifted to
the race of Men…
But they were all of them deceived...for another
Ring was made... a Master Ring to control
all others...
One Ring to rule them all!”
With a origin story clocking in at 6 minutes,
the film situates us firmly in this complex
world.
For an even leaner example, consider Star
Wars epic rolling title card that introduces
you to an intergalactic space war in the time
it takes to unwrap a candy bar.
Both films orient audiences quickly, and then
they’re off to the races.
Bright’s origin story, on the other hand,
is just plain messy; divulged in sloppy, repetitive,
yet incomplete fragments.
But before we analyze the world-building strategies,
a brief overview of the myth behind it: Two
thousand years ago something gnarly went down
with a Dark Lord.
All the Orcs sided with him, except this one
guy, Jirak, who somehow united the nine races
together (Who are the nine races??
Unclear - We’ve got elves, humans, orcs,
fairies, and, for the eagle-eyed viewer, centaurs)
But anyway, they managed to take down the
Dark Lord.
Except oops, he’s ready to come back, and
all his demon elves need to do is bring three
wands together.
Watch out though, only a Bright can hold a
wand, which creates complications.
Still, even if the Dark Lord does rise, he
can be stopped with magic…
That whole subplot never comes to fruition
though - probably to be saved for the recently-greenlit
sequel that will hopefully come with some
clarification.
Now, it’s totally understandable that the
minds behind Bright wanted to veer away from
the dramatically-narrated story-book-style
opener of Lord of the Rings.
It’s not exactly the freshest turf in the
screenwriting world.
Or it... would be understandable, if Bright
hadn’t started out with an equally cheesy
but less eloquent quote that sounds like it
came out of a 10-year-old’s Dungeon and
Dragons game.
From there, they have an opening sequence
of cringeworthy tagging (You’d think with
90 million dollars they could afford to hire
a decent LA graffiti artist??)
Through this, we learn that there’s inter-species
upheaval, police brutality, and…
Lizard People roaming the streets?
It pretty rude to tease the existence of Lizard
People and not deliver, but I digress.
These shots of the street explain some atmospheric
aspects of the film’s world but we’re
still missing the cold hard facts.
For instance, who is the Dark Lord?
And what did he do?
Why are all the social media influencers Elves?
We weren’t the only people scratching our
heads.
After fans expressed widespread confusion
as to what the heck was going on with this
Dark Lord stuff, Netflix released what amounted
to a 2-minute INSTRUCTION MANUAL for the film.
In it, we were given a few thousands years
of magical history, with factual nuggets like:
“Jirak was hailed as the first Bright.”
But if Jirak saved everyone, why do people
hate orcs so damn much??
And how did this world’s social order come
about?
This video feels more like a hastily-concocted
admission of guilt that this film was confusing
as hell.
Another world-building issue is the way the
film conveys the limited information it does
tell the audience.
Which brings us to a fundamental screenwriting
rule: “showing vs. telling.”
Showing is when a film conveys information
through characters’ actions.
Telling is when characters chat about the
events of the world - the narrative equivalent
of an intel briefing for the audience.
And boy is Bright is a tell-a-thon.
Throughout the film, characters regularly
serve as embedded narrators, a strategy that
swallows the action and creates stiff, unrealistic
dialogue.
For instance, the award for worst line in
the film goes to Ward’s daughter in this
cringer.
"Why do you have to be a policeman?
Everyone hates policemen."
OK.
We get it.
Another prime example comes from Ward early
on: “Hey look, I got a dude in my car, the
whole world is watching, aight.
I didn’t ask for it.
I don’t want it.
But I don’t get a vote.”
First of all, this speech is stupendously
heavy handed.
Nobody talks like this.
Secondly, these facts can be SHOWN in a natural
way through the narrative.
In fact, Ward makes it PRETTY clear he’d
rather be shat on by a Fairy then ride to
work alongside Jakoby.
Still, the winner for most forced proxy narrator
has to be the Smelly Sword-Wielding Bum, who
goes from trying to samurai a crowd of people
to calmly relaying the entire world’s backstory
without even a shower-break.
“The army of nice races fought shoulder
to shoulder to give you the world you neglect...
and now the dark one returns to reclaim orc
hearts.”
Then as the Feds interrogate him, he gives
a plodding explanation of the shield of light,
Inferni, wands, the dark lord, Leyla, Tikka,
and Bright.
This scene is A. boring and B. doesn’t make
sense unless you assume federal agents in
charge of Magic Crime are as fucking confused
by the rules of their world as we are.
This strategy continues throughout the film.
Once Jakoby and Ward find the magic wand and
call for backup, four skeezy cops show up
and give us another forced lecture on...
How magic works.
"That's magic right there.
That's whatever you want.
You want a million dollars?
You want ten million?
You wanna be taller or shorter or make your
dick bigger?
You wanna go back in time and marry the girl
who didn't blow you on prom night?
That's how you do it right there."
They continue to narrate the plot, as if the
audience would be absolutely flummoxed by
the concept of dirty cops.
It’s cleary done for the audiences’ sake,
and its corny as hell.
The script spoon feeds us huge plot points
and small details alikes -- Like when Ward,
Jakoby and Tikka are fleeing the Mexican gang
and Ward yells: "Windows up!
Bulletproof!"
Is he patronizing Jakoby, or the audience?
Who even knows.
Just for fun, they remind us: "Bulletproof,
Dickhead!"
Needless plot exposition, dickhead.
Sometimes this tiresome exposition manages
to somehow be both forced AND incomplete.
For instance, Jakoby gives a snooze-inducing
AND scattered explanation of his Orcan Idol
Jirak: “He was a farmer who changed the
world!"
Ok and?
"They raised their blades to him, and he was
blooded in that very moment."
Ok, so Jirak was a farmer who was… wait
what was that?
"Blooded in that very moment."
Ok, seriously, what is the deal with this
blooding thing?
"He's not blooded.
He's not a part of any blooded clan.
He's like a finger that got cut off the hand.
He's dead to us"
Jakoby, who is not blooded, explains that
it’s a sign of honour in the Orc community:
“What you did tonight, that’s what it
takes for an orc to get blooded.
An act of great bravery.”
So, are we supposed to think that all these
other orcs are brave except Jacobi, the one
who professionally puts his life in harm’s
way?
And what does blooding even MEAN?
Jakoby's sad dental situation as compared
to his brethren suggests it’s definitely
tooth related.
We finally get a peek at this blooding ritual
at the end of the film after Jakoby saves
Ward and the same orcs who..were… only half
an hour ago KILLED him slit their palms because
clan loyalty means never having to say you’re
sorry.
At least that’s showing, not telling.
Gold star.
If only we understood what the heck is going
on or how this crowd of orcs knew that Jakoby
had just committed an act of bravery.
Is there some kind of orc bat signal?
Were they just following Jakoby all night,
waiting to shed blood which would magically
give Jakoby the perfect orc smile?
On the bright side, the next day, Jakoby appears
to be teething on his new fangs.
Moving on to Head Scratcher #2 - Hero, Schmero
- Whether you’re writing about outer space,
downtown Baltimore, or a wizarding school
in an English castle, the first ingredient
of a good story is a hero.
Or two.
Or three.
In Bright we have Ward and Jakoby, and neither
will undergo significant character development
over the course of the film.
Ward begins the film as a snarky dickhead,
and ends the film as a snarky dickhead.
"Think you a big dog now.
You blooded huh?"
Jakoby begins as a toothless insecure guy
who can’t stand up for himself, "How are
your holes?"
"How the fuck do you make a shootout awkward."
"Sorry.
Sorry."
and ends the film as a slightly toothed guy
who Ward still treats like a tattooed Forrest
Gump.
"Jakoby, thank the nice officers!"
Beyond that, for a film centered on an unlikely
friendship, their relationship also seems
pretty stagnant.
At best, it could be said that Ward learns
to “tolerate” Jakoby and not narc on him,
which is pretty bleak as far as buddy films
go.
It’s not surprising that they never change
though because they never really had character
journeys to begin with.
The number one rule in making a compelling
hero, according to Aaron Sorkin, is that "Somebody's
gotta want something, something's got to be
standing in their way of getting it.
You do that and you'll have a scene."
Eventually, you’ll have a movie too.
Wesley wants Princess Buttercup, Ferris Bueller
wants to cut class and party, and so on.
In Bright, not so much.
Ward doesn’t appear to actively want anything
except maybe to lose Jakoby as a partner and
keep his job without being a corrupt asshole.
That said, he doesn’t pursue those goals
in any meaningful way.
Jakoby does want to be blooded but, as explained
earlier, we don’t really understand what
the heck being blooded is or what it means
for him as a character.
Does he have to submit to clan loyalty and
hang out with those Miami orcs?
They seemed fun!
While a “want” makes a hero initially
compelling, the hero’s choices are what
makes a character stay compelling.
Apparently, Dustin Hoffman won’t even sign
onto a movie unless his character has no less
than 40 points of choice in the script.
Rather than 40 points of choice, our main
guys face approximately 40 points of coincidences
that save their butts.
Such a coincidence is called a Deus Ex Machina,
or a “person or thing (as in fiction or
drama) that appears suddenly and provides
a contrived solution to an apparently insoluble
difficulty.”
Most notable among these is the Wand.
In one instance, the wand solves the inconvenience
of Jakoby dying.
In another, Ward’s totally random status
as a Bright turns what would have been an
act of suicide into a semi-heroic, 100% coincidental
feat.
Now for Head Scratcher #3 - When a metaphor
is a train wreck.
Bright is littered with unsubtle metaphors
comparing “interspecies discrimination”
with real world racial discrimination.
Even Chance the Rapper called the metaphor
“a little shallow.”
We more than a little agree, but before we
take a deep dive into the meanings at play,
we want to give the following disclaimer:
Yes, this is a fictional world in which nine
races coexist with varying levels of friction.
MAYBE the filmmakers had no intention of it
being read as a precise metaphor for American
racial politics.
Problem is, the movie practically BEGS you
to draw this comparison.
First off, it’s a film about COPS set in
LA, a city that was home to one of the country’s
most violent race riots EVER, one which was
specifically ignited by police violence towards
black folks.
Bright VERY deliberately draws comparisons
between Orcs and black Americans in ways that
are too obvious to ignore.
From the graffiti to the urban streetwear,
visual adaptations of black culture abound.
They’re marginalized by other races in society
and face victimisation at the hands of the
police.
In truly sophisticated symbolism, the film
suggests the cops would definitely kill
the “hooded orc.”
Just for fun, one orc tells Jakoby “Your
buddy is so happy to say he has an Orc friend.”
not knowing that Ward VERY dramatically “doesn’t
do friends."
Oh jeez dude, save it for your Centaur therapist.
That metaphor is referenced most disturbingly
when Jakoby is hung by a rope during a fight
scene with an elf.
I don’t need to spell out why putting a
character that has been signified as black
in this situation is seriously messed up.
Oh, and one VERY important distinction between
Orcs and black Americans?
Orcs apparently CAUSED their oppression, or
at least their great-great-great-grand-orc
daddies did when they decided to side with
the Dark Lord.
“Orcs chose the wrong side a long time ago
and they've been paying for it ever since."
Needless to say, real racial prejudice does
not work that way.
I.e.
Black Americans have zero sins to pay for.
When you’re making a metaphor about race,
it’s important to be very, very precise
- because there’s a real danger that an
ill conceived metaphor can muddle an already
complicated conversation.
To understand why, let’s examine the cognitive
function of metaphors.
In their influential book, “Metaphors We
Live by,” scholars George Lakoff and Mark
Johnson explain that metaphors are vital to
human being’s understanding of the world
around us.
That’s because metaphors are a way of taking
a human’s understanding of a simple, often
physically tangible concept and transferring
that understanding onto another, more complicated
concept, often one hidden from our senses
or difficult to explain.
Lakoff & Johnson argue that when we make a
metaphor, say comparing “madness” to “love,”
we’re not just momentarily linking two ideas.
We’re also transferring an extensive array
of our cognitive associations about what constitutes
f “madness” onto “love.”
As a result, a human struggling to write a
Valentine card can explain why they have butterflies
in their belly.
As a result, “Metaphors may create realities
for us, especially social realities leading
us to “view..
The metaphor as being true.”
So in this case: Lovers be cray.
SO what does all this have to do fictional
orcs?
When a film like Bright unsubtly evokes a
metaphor that transfers the viewer’s understanding
of the inhuman orcs onto “black Americans”
they inherently invite the possibility that
viewers will transfer all their cognitive
associations about what constitutes orcs -- a
“race” of homogenous, inarticulate tattooed
gangsters on to that of the extremely complex,
and most importantly HUMAN group of black
Americans.
It’s not like Bright will radically harm
race relations, but this practice does place
it somewhere in an ugly history of American
cinema comparing people of color to inhuman
“creatures.
Before we go further into this, it’s important
to address the colorblind elephant in the
room: Bright depicts a world where a black
man of Ward’s status can exist seemingly
without facing bigotry.
Or to quote Chance the Rapper, “...racism
is gone... cause we hate ork now.”
That’s messed up - More so even when you
couple it with Ward’s treatment of marginalised
creatures, all of which evoke treatment of
black Americans by police officers.
Whether he’s saying, "Fairy Lives Don't
Matter Today."
or watching a bunch of Orcs get beat up then
asking Jakoby: “I need to know if you’re
a cop first or an orc first…” it just
feels...odd.
In a country where violence against black
men by police officers remains heartbreakingly
common, depicting a black cop this way just
feels way way off the mark.
Ward’s character seems to be there to both
protect the film against charges of racism
(How can a movie be racist when it shows a
black man as equal and even getting to be
racist himself!) and to make a backwards argument
about how “far” black America has come,
through an individual representation of a
black man whose “made it” and “earned
respect.”
Now back to the specifics of the film’s
depiction of Orcs, which make it even more
icky.
While Jakoby is an honorable guy with a working
moral compass, his depiction is not particularly
flattering.
For starters, and there’s no easy way to
say this: Jakoby is not the sharpest.
This is most painfully obvious near the end
of the film, when Jakoby cannot stop spilling
incriminating evidence to two federal agents.
"He turned around, sight unseen, all four
of them, bang bang bang bang."
The film doesn’t make it better when Ward
tells his daughter: “All of the races are
... uh ... different."
While there’s something to be said for respecting
ethnic and cultural differences, Ward's comments
seem to suggest the existence of actual biological
racial differences.
"Do Orcs uhh have mad hops?
How many Orcs are ballers?"
"Excuse me?"
"You f***in heard the detective.
How many orcs play pro basketball?"
"None.
They're slow, they're heavy, that's why half
the NFL defensive lines are Orcish.
It's not racism.
It's physics."
And yes, they’re fictional characters who
are literally of different species - but the
metaphor still evokes black Americans and
it feels plain weird.
That’s coupled with Jakoby's clear inability
to match Ward’s intellect, which falls into
the trap of evoking hundreds of years of junk
racist biology that tried to excuse racism
on the grounds that people of color were intellectually
inferior.
At the same time, giving orcs a super strong
sense of smell gives them an “animalistic”
quality that; Again, makes the metaphor super
ugly, particularly when you consider the hundreds-year
long history of white Americans treating black
American like subhuman beings.
As Lakoff and Johnson explains, “What is
at issue is not the truth or falsity of a
metaphor but the perceptions and inferences
that follow from it and the actions that are
sanctioned by it.”
Metaphors like the one in Bright, in comparing
people of color to inhuman beings, are fucked
up even if they had good intentions.
And as, Lakoff and Johnson explain, “We
define our reality in terms of metaphors and
then proceed to act.”
Though it makes some superficial points about
tolerance, and encourages the audience to
empathize with Jakoby’s experiences of marginalization,
abusive friendships and “kick me” signs,
Bright’s overarching metaphor is just plain
sloppy.
Bright let us down.
But given our world of inevitable sequels,
threequels and squeakuels, we suspect elves
and orcs will be duking it out on your favorite
streaming platform for years to come.
And we’re not mad at it.
Netflix has a cool concept to work with, and,
in case you haven’t heard, a disgusting
amount of dough to throw at it.
Here’s hoping the sequel gives us something
special.
Thanks for watching, guys.
Peace.